creating photorealistic materials for
light transport algorithms requires
carefully fine-tuning a set of material
properties to achieve a desired artistic
effect this is a lengthy process that
involves a trained artist with
specialized knowledge in this work we
propose a system that only requires
basic image processing knowledge and
enables users without photorealistic
rendering experience to create high
quality materials this is highly
desirable as human thinking is
inherently visual and not based on
physically based material parameters in
our proposed workflow all the user needs
to do is apply a few intuitive
transforms to a source image and in the
next step our technique produces the
closest photorealistic material that
approximates this target image one of
our key observations is that even though
this process target image is often not
physically achievable in many cases a
photorealistic material model can be
found that closely matches this image
our method generates results in less
than 30 seconds and works in the
presence of poorly edited target images
like the discoloration of the pedestal
or the background of the gold material
here this technique is especially useful
early in the material design process
where the artist seeks to rapidly
iterate over a variety of possible
artistic effects
we also proposed an extension to predict
image sequences with a tight budget of
one to two seconds per image
to achieve this we propose a simple
optimization formulation that is able to
produce accurate solutions but takes
relatively long due to the lack of a
useful initial guess our other main
observation is that an approximate
solution can also be achieved without an
optimization step by implementing a
simple encoder neural network the main
advantage of this method is that it
produces a solution within a few
milliseconds with the drawback that the
provided solution is only approximate we
refer to this as the inversion technique
both of these solutions suffer from
drawbacks the optimization approach
provides results that resemble the
target image but is impracticable due to
the fact that it requires too many
function evaluations and get stuck in
local minima whereas the inversion
technique rapidly produces a solution
but is more approximate in nature we
show that the best aspects of these two
solutions can be fused together into a
hybrid method that initializes our
optimizer with the prediction of the
neural network this hybrid method opens
up the possibility of creating novel
materials by stitching together the best
aspects of two or more materials
deleting unwanted features through image
in painting contrast enhancement or even
fusing together two materials
these synthesized materials can also be
easily inserted into already existing
scenes by the user in this scene we made
a material mixture to achieve a richer
Nebula effect inside the glass
we also show in the paper that this
hybrid method not only gives a head
start to the optimizer by endowing it
with a useful initial guess but provides
strictly higher quality outputs than any
of the two previous solutions on all of
our test cases
furthermore if at most a handful of
materials are sought the total modelling
times reveal that our technique compares
favorably to previous work on mascara
material synthesis we believe this
method will offer an appealing entry
point for novices into the world of
photorealistic material modeling thank
you for your attention